Social Security and Medicare are
problems there are problems waiting to
happen if you look at social security
first of all we're going to have a
problem in about 10 years right now
we're sort of in surplus but the
Congress is spending the surplus money
and what we need to do is we need to
look at both sides of the Social
Security equation we need to figure out
a way to get more revenues into the
system and a way to adjust the benefits
we've got to take into account longevity
social security was set up when you know
people live to be 65 now they live to be
85 and so we need to do something about
that but this is this is not rocket
science this is something that we could
do if we sat down and the two parties
reason together and so that what makes
it so frustrating from a Medicare
standpoint Medicare is not sustainable
in its current form but that's because
health care is not sustainable in its
current form Medicare is a kind of a
subset of health care and it's the
health care system that we have to fix
Social Security is as big as it is it's
the easy one what we could do is is get
the two parties together and what I've
been saying in Congress is look it's
going to take two miracles to fix Social
Security one miracle is that you
Republicans and Democrats are going to
have to sit down at the same table and
reason together and come up with a fair
equitable plan for long-term solvency
and the second miracle is that the
public is going to have to buy it and I
think that AARP can help deliver on that
second miracle when we go out and talk
to our members and other you know
elements of the public we lay out Social
Security we tell them what the problems
are and they are willing to engage it's
not the third rail that politicians like
to talk about so we can get that one
done political will is what we need the
other one Medicare as I say
the conversation we had on health care
is where we have to go we've got to
squeeze down costs which we can do we've
got to cover the uninsured which we can
do and we've got to improve quality of
care through things like health
information technology and electronic
prescribing so that we cut down the
errors in health care and improve the
quality of care we can do all these
things but it's very hard because of the
complexity of the system and because of
the political stalemate in which we find
ourselves it's a tough question people
do not like that idea now you know if
you're 41 or under right now you're
going to have to work to your 67 but at
the same time many people want to work
into their older years there's another
way to think about it which has been
called longevity indexing and some
countries do this and what they
basically say is ok let's actually
figure out how long you're expected to
live and we'll give you your Social
Security money stretched out over that
period of time so you get less money per
year over a longer period of years
that's one way to think about it there
are a lot of ways to consider fixing
this